hallo mein name ist khan herzlich
willkommen feuchtes zu einem neuen video
von mir meine damen und herren ich
befinde mich in meinem zimmer sondern am
strand dass sie gar dass ich im urlaub
bin mit ein paar freunden ort sich hier
und hier sind spazieren der hand halten
schnauzte eingeblendet das jetzt
möglichkeit der rauschbrille also eine
brille die einst selbst den eindruck
vermitteln wenn man sie aufwand als wäre
man betrunken ich hatte diese brille
bisher erst einmal auf wir alle hatten
nicht einmal kurz auf also wir haben da
noch nicht so wirklich was mitgemacht
haben und ich bin trainiert deswegen
habe ich gedacht wir machen heute
bereits challenges am strand aber zuerst
einmal stelle ich euch die teilnehmer
dieser challenge erforschen denkt die
erde sei eine scheibe sarah zweiter
vorname alkohol chris ist solo doch
klopapier moritz hat sand in der porsche
also noch so straff foto johannes denk
das emos im zoo leben
sandra hat heute extra deo benutzt das
team kennt meine damen und herren würd
ich sagen kann direkt mit der ersten
teile die sich schon hier fordert ein
tor und wir haben hier einen fußball und
hier ist eine entfernung von 6
20 die erste aufgabe wird jetzt also
seien dreimal sich mit der brille auf
anlauf zu nehmen und mit dem ball auf
das tor zu schießen
das heißt ich würde sagen dass niemand
das sind fertig los okay chris erste
umdrehungen 2000 drehungen und seine
dritte umdrehung jetzt auf den walzen
ich will einfach mal ganz kurz eben das
logo sehen
nein dieser stelle sehen wir bei chris
punkte stand als nächstes würde ich
sagen sandra du bist anders
[Musik]
dann geschah das für dich hier siehst du
hier gestanden
ich würde sagen trainings technisch bin
ich am besten aufgestellt weil ich die
brille er bestellt habe und schon 12 mal
auf hatten aber ich glaube aber dass wir
trotzdem schwierig
solo kann jetzt habe ich hier nochmal
der punktestand eingeblendet los drei
umdrehungen auf meine damen und herren
und die dritte umdrehung wir sehen hier
vor den banken gelände
das ist echter wünsche betroffen
an der stelle auch noch mal deinen
punktestand dann einblenden fertig und
umdrehung nummer eins umdrehung nummer
zwei und umdrehung nummer drei für
johannes hier meine damen und herren und
losgeht wir sehen ihn bald ein kleinod
sie gut ist an der stelle auch für dich
leider so sarah sitzt ja auch zum ersten
mal die brille auf tatsächlich sonst
erlebt sie diesen zustand tatsächlich
mit alkohol
wow schön umdrehungen nummer eins das
ist bisher die langsam zu bringen die
ich je gesehen habe
aber wie lange da wirklich drehst dich
ab was tust du ja auch auf ball zu
kommen
das ist so wie christian du four soft
freistoß nicht so gut hat sich doch
sarah ist die herzliche weiter nach
hinten befördert als tutor hin auch an
der stelle für dich deine punktestand
hier eingeblendet
auf die plätze fertig los
moritz unser letzter kandidat in der
runde ergibt auf jeden falschen ton ich
vollgas hier freunde und er hat jetzt
zum drehbuch noch den ball zu und ich
dachte erst an zu schreien das war schon
regel verschluckt er trotzdem montag ein
problem auch an der stelle wo finde ich
den punktestand kommen wir nun zum
channel x 2 meine sehr verehrten damen
und herren hier erstmal noch mal kurz
der zwischenstand jetzt gerade
jetzt schon mal zwei ist ähnlich
aufgebaut und zwar haben wir hier wieder
den stock man muss allerdings ich lieber
nicht in stockum drehen sein man hat die
brille aus startet bei diesem stoff
lautlos zu diesen fall der euroleague
drehen sich immer um den ball kommen
läuft hier vorne weiter zu den beach
soccer turnier um die natur wo man dann
so schnell es geht wieder zurück hier zu
diesem stock und das tier nicht die zeit
sondern die zeit also nicht die punkte
sondern die zeit sehen und diese
mahlzeit ich würde sagen an der stelle
wieder ladies first
das macht sich in folge findet hier
vorne die stoppuhr und quasi stoppt die
zeit wie lange es braucht das heißt
chris bist du fertig direkt schnell los
derzeit sind sie 02 ich glaube dass ging
einigermaßen klar
sandra hier als nächste das heißt auch
für dich sandra 321 sie läuft natürlich
schon vorher los aber das sei ihm
verziehen
sie läuft hier direkt warum macht das
bringt nimmt den ball mit dem und jetzt
kommen wir zum tor freunde und ich
glaube nicht dass das was wird sagte
aber wir warten hier auf jeden fall
schon echt recht gut
weicht den sand fördern aus und ja in
ganz geschafft
22 bisher ist christ immer noch der
führer hier und ich weiß nicht aber das
wohin richtig verstanden aber wir werden
ab jetzt zu machen dass man wenn man von
dem tor hinten kommt dass man dann
phasen direkt zu diesem stock hier läuft
und nicht irgendwie an der seite hier
oder so sondern den stock quasi haben
als ende die sonne wasser berührt
nein
[Musik]
18 jahre war hier auch zeit für freundin
kristi finden sagt hier befinden die
zeit freunde er läuft und den
persönlichen sachen gut gemeistert im
store machte auch einen großen bogen er
noch zurückkommen vorne und gaben die
zeit haben war und es heißt 14 12 okay
finde an der stelle der für hier auf die
plätze fertig los
johannes hier meine damen und herren
ergebnis die sache rangegangen den ball
vorne hat er schnell mitgenommen
das war echt dass man mit eines der
besten über ein manöver nimmt einen
großen bogen hier wird ja auch wir sehen
wir hier läuft das auf jeden fall super
oder läuft er mit dem fasten da haben
wir fordern den stopp und bahnen was die
zeit findet immer noch erster platz 32
mein gott das ist aber gar nicht mal so
schlecht aus geraden uhr und 14 56
moritz die letzte person die hier finden
vom thron stürzen kann was sagst du dazu
probieren tuis auf die plätze fertig los
worin sie und ersten ds so schnell es
noch keinen pushen kommen und so standen
den bahnhof und nicht richtig wo dort
das sieht richtig haben das unter zehn
sekunden
11 10 11 20 wochen
dritte und letzte challenge findet der
fährten zuschauer wir haben hier vorne
eine linie vorbereitet habt hier deutet
man los von dem stock da ganz hinten
dahinter liegt auf der ball und wenn man
dann da hinten ist dritter mit dem wald
zurück wieder über diese linie also hier
eine zeit sache und ich würde sagen
unsere nette dame hier vorne darf wieder
anfangen lassen los chris für dich läuft
die zeit hier läuft auf den stock zu
sehen meine damen und herren und her
läuft um den kanal erneuert den ball
unter den 70 19 7 für sandra los geht's
auch für den wiesmann vermieter zurück
auf die plätze fertig los
ganz nicht einmal mit der kamera vater
neben es gibt auf jeden fall pro watt
endlich vollgas hier vorne da sehen wir
den ball gut mitgenommen vielleicht wird
das der bessere zeitungen alles hatte
jetzt glaube ich ja jetzt
das war sand und das kann er das genau
jetzt kommt wann eigenschaft als
vielleicht war ja genau da ja ja sie
kommt so langsam über die linie und zack
wenn wir uns die zeit 28 10 28 10
eigentlich hat man nur 10 10
[Musik]
wie kannst du mal wieder die linie um
center 28 10 26 10 okay was hab ich das
jetzt so dass circa 16 sekunden
16 sekunden ohne den stehen brauchen
nicht unter den umbau fordert
wahrscheinlich wehgetan aber finde mit
dem balkon ist sehr sehr sehr gut aus
stoppt das war sehr gut so heftig 13.05
los hier sehen die jungs laufen das ist
sehr interessant die die verschiedenen
taktiken zu beobachten die leute laufen
hier ist lag man es einfach den ball
sehr sehr weit vor und wir haben das
auch geschafft ohne gott wie schnell 10
55 10 55 lag man nur bis neuer erster
platz
da geht sie nimmt den ball wurde mit am
stock wird wohl noch nicht dabei war
gedauert hat der bald kommen kommt jakob
park gekommen
das ist also das ist ein tempo das sieht
man das sieht man sonst selten auf dem
platz vergleichen könnten dass sie mit
dem hamburger sportverein und der ball
rollt aber lang gemacht die ihnen
letzten die sagen das ist eine bestimmte
beschissene zeit doch da hat sich den
ball gerade mal oder bambus hörte ich
ihnen hier wird man hier unten sagt
umlauf und bahn aber zeit ist 30 36 30
sekunden auf die plätze fertig los wo
wird mein letzter kandidat hier haben
doch die jungs der die liste hand von
aber moritz ist sehr motiviert hier
starten bisher sehe ich das als zwei
jahre nimmt den ball mit von proben dort
das ist das konnte der gute zeit weder
verliert er den ball verliert wichtige
sekunden hier das traurigkeit 20 01 03
das heißt an der stelle johannes
herzlichen glückwunsch challenge
gewonnen
meine damen und herren das war's jetzt
hier von der challenge moritz hat die
zeit wahrscheinlich gewonnen die erste
challenge
das gerissen und die dritte challenge
gewonnen dass hier beiden dürft jetzt
schnick schnack schnuck machen knick
ich mag meine sieger
ein ganz ganz großes dankeschön an euch
alle fürs mitmachen das hat mir eine
große freude gemacht
ich würde sagen freunde wenn euch das
gefallen hat nicht freunde mit euch das
video gefallen hat das gerne machen
leichter soll ich eventuell noch mal was
mit dieser rauschen oder machen das war
echt lustig und was könnte ich damit
eventuell machen vielleicht einen job
fußballplatz oder sowas schreibt gerne
in die kommentare und jetzt